[Music]
good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime
i'm rachel campos-duffy they called
barack obama the deporter-in-chief
but his former vp joe biden is quickly
cementing his legacy as the
open borders president now he's stopped
border construction he's taken the teeth
out of ice and he's rolled out the red
carpet
for thousands of illegal immigrants
rushing to our southern border
and it's not just conservatives
concerned by his radical immigration
agenda
even some democrats are starting to get
nervous
congressman vicente gonzalez of texas
saying quote
the way we're doing it right now is
catastrophic and it's a recipe for a
disaster
in the middle of a pandemic what's got
them so worried
well let's take a look at biden's plan
it starts
with a path to citizenship for more than
11 million
illegal immigrants currently in this
country
but he's not stopping there his plan
would provide amnesty
to illegal immigrants who have already
been deported by the trump
administration
that could be up to 900 000 people
can we afford to do this well millions
of american citizens
including hispanic americans are
unemployed
the economy is still in shambles thanks
to the pandemic
is now the time to flood our job market
with undocumented workers when our own
people can't find work now vaccines
might help that situation
but guess what they're going to illegal
immigrants too
ice admitted just this week that some
detainees are already being vaccinated
against covet 19 while vulnerable
americans wait
but why should we be surprised joe biden
has made it clear
that his administration will not be
putting
america first joining me now is dan
bongino
host of the dan bongino show and a fox
news contributor
dan thank you so much for joining us
this evening um
it is just a pleasure and an honor to
have you on tonight
thank you thank you good to be here
you've been doing an amazing job by the
way you're really kicking butt over
there i loved it
i've been watching every no i'm not
kidding i watch every night with rap
detention you've been doing spectacular
well thanks yeah we can talk about this
all night but we got to get back to this
immigration policy because
i don't understand why
they're doing this in the middle of a
pandemic when people have lost so much
work
what should why do you think they're
doing it
well because they're irrational they're
liberals i mean the whole essence of
liberalism is you know causing a forest
fire
nationally and never doing anything of
substance ever i mean really
how do liberals wake up every morning
and say hey i'm on the right side of
this i think we should just open the
borders to the united states and not you
know let everybody come in
for any reason i mean how is that fair
to people who went through the legal
citizenship process
but a couple points on this how many
times are we the republicans right
not us but you know the establishment
swampy republicans gonna get
fooled by this they tried in the reagan
years after the simpson masoli bill
passed where they said this they made
this promise rachel you'll see this
every time and the audience you need to
be aware of this
they go oh listen just give us amnesty
for the 20 million people who entered
the country illegally
and i promise you we will do border
security after that
this has already been tried this is like
the lucy
charlie brown football thing like how
many times are we gonna get worked by
this
they're not gonna secure the border so
forget that but the second point is
they're using emotion you know i was
debating geraldo last night
um on hannity show and people use
emotion
in the immigration debate it's a policy
debate it's not emotional
it's very simple when they say things
like well you know people work really
hard when they're here and they deserve
a path to citizenship
okay point taken they probably do work
hard but so do americans number one
and secondly rachel there is a path to
citizenship
you know what it's called it's called
the path to citizenship
if you really want to get crazy you can
call it the citizenship path
just because you chose not to do that
and take the illegal route
is not our fault that's your fault for
doing that
well dan it's policy but it's also
politics i was so fascinated that these
democrat
congressmen i think there's also some
representatives from the texas
legislature along the southern border
remember this is that area where trump
unexpectedly did very well
in the last election nobody thought that
was going to happen the gop invested
no money down there what it tells me is
that maybe they
like the immigration policies maybe they
didn't vote for it in 216
but in 2020 they realized it was working
and keeping the border safe
yeah this is uh what did george w bush
called the soft bigotry of low
expectations when
voters excuse me when politicians out
there talk to hispanic voters
as if they're a monolithic block of
people who can't think for themselves
i mean is there anything more bigoted
than talking to people seriously
talking to people like they're robots
and idiots who can't process information
as if hispanic voters only concern ever
rachel
only is illegal immigration that's they
don't think about anything they're not
moms
they're not teachers they're not you
know workers or
in unions or whatever it may be they're
only concerned about illegal immigration
and that's an
excellent point you just made i want to
highlight will you look at the
performance of donald trump
in south florida heavily hispanic south
florida
even in north florida in the orlando
area which is populated by a large
puerto rican population
he kicked butt he slayed on this on the
texas border
which you just referenced he did
unbelievable historically well
because he said this you're welcome here
come here
we love you everybody coming just do it
the right way it's not hard
just follow the path to citizenship did
you hear
dan that uh tom perez actually said that
it was the russians
that infiltrated florida and somehow
got these hispanics in florida who come
from venezuela and cuba and everywhere
to not like socialism i mean it's just
it's just you're absolutely right they
underestimate us
they think we're monolithic they think
that they can um you know
tell us how to vote and we don't have a
brain
yeah and yeah i mean tom perez you know
it's hard to take anything
he says seriously i mean i'm familiar
with him for my time up in maryland
but uh yeah you're right and they tried
to block everybody in what they tried to
say is no no
donald trump just did well with the
cuban voters because a lot of cuban
voters in south florida
sadly their families have experience
with socialism donald trump spoke out
against socialism but
that's not what i just said what you
know and what i just said is he did well
with
puerto rican voters in the orlando area
too
who they didn't grow up in a socialist
country in cuba i mean you could debate
big government policies in puerto rico
but it's clearly not socialism like in
cuba and as you just said on the texas
border
you have you know first-generation
immigrant families who were like hey
you know this is i came here legally i
didn't sign up for this for my town to
be
invaded by people who don't respect the
law i'm really sorry you broke the law
we have laws here it matters
right and they care about the law
remember that's a over 50
of the border patrol is hispanic so
these are families that are very proud
hispanic families very proud of
protecting our border
um who are offended that people would
think they are for illegal immigration
or that they don't care about safety
um right where they live so anyway dan
you always bring up such great points
i've been
begging for you to come on my show all
week and you finally relented so
thanks so much for joining us gonna skip
the opportunity to talk to the great
rachel campos duffy you kidding no it's
great being with seriously you're not
getting out of park good job
thanks dan all right all